he is showing what a defensive Force he
can be now for Virginia you got to take
care of the ball against the pressure
you're going to see is the most
important thing here get it in plainly
handle the initial trap that you're
gonna get and then make free throws if
you force them to fat or the Cavaliers
are playing with four guards and the
four guards out there along with Cedric
are their best free throw shooters Clark
in a straight jacket
he threw it away being produced
Virginia
did we just see what we think we just
saw wow
Kihei Clark thinks he can throw the ball
down the court and run the timeout but
as soon as that pass is intercepted now
suddenly you have a scramble situation
Virginia cannot set its defense
and another big basket by Foster or is
that one Foster those Piggies but geese
who is not a great three-point shooter
but he rises up and match that one in
his first one of the game but
sunbound 2.4 they added a little bit of
time it's Beekman good if it goes
[Applause]